mais l'europe n'a été autant danger nous
dit le prétendant public il y a urgence
c'est donc par ces mots qu'il a choisi
de s'adresser aux citoyens de 28 pays de
l'union dans sa tribune qui est publié
aujourd'hui une dramatisation de l'enjeu
donc suivi d'une série de propositions
vous allez nous dire ce que vous en
pensez
est ce que cette tribune du président de
la république vous a convaincu au
contraire n'est-elle qu'un catalogue de
bonnes intentions
tout cela on va en parler on écoute
d'abord nathalie l'oiseau ministre des
affaires européennes elle explique elle
qu'il y à deux enjeux et deux façons de
voir l'europe on écoute on voit bien
aujourd'hui deux types de européens ceux
qui se contentent du statu quo qui ont
l'impression que finalement préservé
l'europe telle qu'elle est ce serait
suffisant alors qu'on voit la colère des
peuples
et puis ceux qui vendent le simplisme
d'une réponse de repli national qui est
le contraire de ce dont on a besoin et
nous on répond l'europe doit être à la
hauteur des attentes des européens et
des besoins du quotidien des citoyens
nathalie l'oiseau qui était l'invité du
toc ce matin du figaro stéphane marchand
comme le dit nathalie l'oiseau la
tribune est elle à la hauteur de la
colère des peuples
moi je me méfie de l'expression la
colère des peuples parce qu'elle est une
fois qu'elle est prononcé le mot peuple
ça me semble ça me gêne un tout petit
peu moi je ne connais pas anodin là
parce que populisme oui ce qui est ce
qui est certain c'est que cette lettre
est un catalogue de bonnes intentions
mais c'est pas parce que c'est un
catalogue de voeux pieux
il faut bien qu'une voix s'élèvent en
europe pour dire ce que emmanuel macron
vient d'écrire dans sa tribune ceux qui
prétendent que la seule protection qui
va hisser la protection de la nation se
trompe on entend ça ces jours-ci revenir
comme harbulot et on se souvient
peut-être que slobodan milosevic avait
prononcé ces mêmes paroles au début de
la guerre de bosnie au début des années
90 donc moi je trouve qu'il a raison de
dramatiser l'enjeu
l'enjeu est l'enjeu est tout à fait
exceptionnelle et le fait de brandir en
permanence le mot deux peuples et le mot
deux nations est extrêmement dangereux
et en plus ça à ça ça semble confirmer
toute une série de
de faussetés qui sont répétés absolument
qu en permanence sur l'union européenne
et son fonctionnement qui est
extrêmement complexe et je reconnais
difficilement compréhensible mais il
faut le vrai travail qu'il faut faire
c'est montrer à quel point l'union
européenne en réalité à protéger raison
dramatiser l'enjeu alexis moi je pense
pas qu il dramatise moi ce qui me frappe
c'est l'aspect de normalisation des
discours ma chronique et un discours qui
a des aspérités très forte en bien en
mal on va en parler mais hélas je trouve
qu'il est revenu dans un discours aux
secours en secret en gros ils ont été
signés par raffarin dont on parlera tout
à l'heure par le maire par même alain
juppé il aura plus de ça il n'y a rien
de choquant pour quelqu'un de droit qui
a peut-être que gens de gauche ont
trouvé que ça manque un peu de social
mais c'est au fond un discours très
mainstream et ça me paraît très très en
arrière et de ce point du moi je m'en
réjouis mais je pense qu'elles ont honte
de ma connaissance désole ça me paraît
très en arrière de ce qui était sa
position à lui ça fait quand même deux
ans et demi qui nous explique que c'est
l'europe et le chant le champ clos de la
bataille entre les nationalistes et les
progressistes entre les populismes
opportuniste ans les filles aiment ou
pas mais il ya plus a disparu c'est
maintenant et dix bombes et tant mieux
de il dit le breakbeat c'est pas la
mauvaise volonté d' horribles populiste
qui rompt le désir de mal faire et dit
c'est simplement la conséquence d'une
crise est sans doute que l'europe ne
fonctionne pas bien
il était temps de le voir tant mieux
c'est bien de le voir mais c'est quand
même ça me paraît absolument absolument
nouveau et donc 2 2 voilà il ya un côté
on rentre on rentre dans le rang et
l'autre aspect très idéaliste qui était
le sien 13 européiste très l'horizon
européen la supranationalité tout tout
ce côté là il abandonne aussi il est
plus du tout question de souveraineté
européenne
c'est fini ça il revient du secours il
faut qu'on améliore notre et et qu'on
discute ensemble entre nation et on va
s'arranger
donc c'est vous tous vous êtes à
stéphane est un peu restée à lancer un
discours de maquereaux il me paraît
beaucoup plus raisonnable aujourd'hui
alors moins enthousiasmant pour les
les européistes farouche mais plus
raisonnable et sans doute bas du cou
dans sa lettre il parle de souveraineté
européenne sur les entreprises par
exemple il expie lannoy phase très mal
entrés dans le détail on va remplir une
règle que l'on doit protéger tant mieux
renée fregosi justo vous donne la parole
avant de revenir sur les propositions
pragmatisme alors on emmanuel macron
finalement écouté
j'interprète pas ce que veut ou pas
emmanuel macron je ne sais pas du tout
moi je ne sais jamais ce qu'il veut donc
la graine on lui dira peut-être
voilà donc c'est plutôt à vous de nous
préciser mais ce que je pense d'eux
d'abord je pense qu'il est légitime
qu'il s'adresse à tous les européens
donc ça c'est la méthode pas de moi j'y
vois pas d'inconvénient s'est passé mais
quand les autres exactement fait
exactement tout à fait bien sûr nous
aurons effectivement donc ça ok c'est
légitime en effet il insiste moins sur
l'opposition nationalisme européiste ça
c'est assez juste
le problème c'est que il ne précise pas
de quelle européisme il parle et moi
effectivement moi je suis très heureux
pays sts dans le sens où je pense en
effet que aujourd'hui dans notre stade
actuel de la mondialisation
capitalistique l'état nation ne peut
plus protégés de la même façon qu'avant
mais pour cela pour à nouveau trouver
des moyens à la fois de redistribuer et
de protéger il faut effectivement une
europe fédérale mais le dire carrément
c'est-à-dire est exactement et ne le dit
valeur marchande en avant ses besoins
donc moi ça me va mais vous non
voilà exactement parce que moi en fait
ce que je voudrais c'est un état
européen
donc ça ne peut pas être un état nation
bien sûr ça peut être un état fédéral
donc un état fédéré de plusieurs nations
mais un état c'est à dire un état avec
des frontières un état avec une
unification fiscales et sociales un état
qui est susceptible donc de d'attraper
le capitalisme de lui faire redistribuer
directement aux citoyens européens est
un état qui se protège d'une immigration
massive
donc effectivement il évoque un petit
peu mais on sait pas trop où il va et ce
que je crains c'est que ça avait pas
beaucoup de soin à couper coup d'épée
dans l'eau
il a ainsi tué l'on peut pour ajouter à
ce que vit renée fregosi on peut aussi
dire pas encore de tête de liste pas
beaucoup d'alliés en europe
bon effectivement des mots des mots
disent les cris paquet moi j'ai envie de
vous d'essayer de vous réconcilier tous
les deux en dis parce que je crois que
ce qui est nouveau ce qui est nouveau
dans enfin ce texte me semble dans le
prolongement de ce qui a pu être fait
les dernières semaines mais c'est alain
fleisher moi ce que je trouve je veux
pas d'un point d'inflexion mais je crois
que ce qui moi ce que je lis dans ce
texte c'est d'abord une prise en compte
des inquiétudes c'est à dire qu'il ya de
grandes inquiétudes les inquiétudes
elles sont identitaire et le les
inquiétudes elles sont liées à
l'environnement elles sont liées à la
sécurité et elles sont liées à comme
vous disais tout à l'heure la
mondialisation le modèle social dans
cette mondialisation est actionné la
protection aussi de notre économie
dans un monde où on est face à des jets
des géants extra européens qui nous
menacent et donc je crois que parce que
je trouve très positif dans ce texte et
qui quelque part vous réconcilie c'est
de dire on prend en compte ces
inquiétudes ces inquiétudes qui sont des
inquiétudes pour la souveraineté
française et pour tout ce que je viens
d'énoncer il fait partie des éléments de
la souveraineté française mais on dit en
même temps que c'est ces inquiétudes la
elles seront beaucoup mieux protégés
dans un cadre européen
alors je pense pas que le fédéralisme
soit du tout d'actualité je pense que ça
fait longtemps que cette idée là
n'a pas n'a pas été exprimée par le
président dont je ne vois pas
d'inflexion sur ce point mais l'idée que
oui il ne me parle pas souvent
il en parle plus ce qui est important
c'est qu'il y avait souvent des
françaises ont les plus voir de penser
qu'il puisse y avoir une souveraineté
française digne de ce nom dans le
contexte qui est le nôtre sans sens une
forte une refondation de l'europe aussi
bien sur le plan sécurité mais je crois
que vous avez bien fait avoir il faut
pas seulement de leur foi refonte dna
vous terminez avec une vidéo ayant suivi
cette affaire en saxe qui sont énoncés
qui sont l'environnement la sécurité
lala et j'insiste sur le fait que le mot
frontières et expériences avec
insistance et prononce avec insistance
est également le mot valeur est
évidemment le choix du mot renaissance
européenne comme ça je crois moi je ce
texte est je crois aussi une réponse à
tous ceux qui se disent mon inquiétude
ne conduit à douter de l'europe
en fait l'europe telle qu'elle est n'est
pas satisfaisante mais il faut faire une
europe autrement mais sans europe la
france sera faible et la souveraineté
française sera serein à l'heure stéphane
il suffit de se promener en chine par
exemple et auprès des responsables
chinois pour les voir attendent avec
impatience que le projet européen échoue
et qu'ils aient eu à traiter un par un
avec des pays qui de leur point de vue
sont absolument minuscule première chose
deuxième chose mais maintenant avec qui
a pas que les chinois une latte et les
américains ensuite dans la lettre quand
on lit la lettre quand on lit
sanctionner ou interdire en europe les
entreprises qui portent atteinte à nos
intérêts stratégiques nos valeurs
essentielles
c'est de la souveraineté c'est une
métaphore de la souveraineté assumer une
préférence européenne
c'est une métaphore de la souveraineté
contre la menace des lobbys évaluation
scientifique indépendante
c'est une métaphore de la souveraineté
donc il en parle quand même il enfin
souveraineté européenne qui va à
l'unisson de la france bien sûr bien sûr
et à deuxièmement aime bien sûr ni le
projet fédéral n'existe mans il n'y aura
pas d'europe fédérale ça c'est clair en
revanche c'est reconnaissant que le
brent et sa patte fédéralisme à
souverain c'est une fête unique un
souverain le souverain ya peu par deux
souverains dans la main
psg revient au dessus de nous j'essayais
de terminale qui est vrai c'est que le
processus européen voilà processus
d'intégration le clou zabuti de
l'histoire à part évidemment les états
eux mêmes mais sinon le processus
européen n'est pas fédéral certes mais
il est très très très intégré déjà
n'oublions pas tous ceux qui ont intégré
n'oublions pas la concurrence n'oublions
pas le commerce international n'oublions
pas tous les sujets sur lequel l'europe
a réussi l'intégration de sumo
formidable et une efficacité redouté
dans le monde entier
quelques internautes et de leurs
réactions sur ce sujet compliqué mais
passionnant alors monsieur babineau
dudit on peut critiquer la personnalité
de macron mais il est droit dans ses
bottes et courageux c'est admirable et
il continue en avant emmanuel macron
n'avance pas masqué contrairement à
laurent wauquiez qui penche très adroite
r34 de son 9e point de vue il est pas
masquer r34 l'europe telle que la voit
macron par sa réaction béate face à
l'immigration massive est un danger on
va parler d'immigration effectivement et
nicole qui ajoute pour sa part la
logorrhée verbale ou écrite de macron me
fatigue des mots des mots et on attend
toujours quelque chose de concret alors
parmi les choses concrètes on va les
voir s'afficher à l'écran on en a retenu
quelques unes parmi les propositions
il ya donc l'idée d'interdire le
financement des partis par des
puissances étrangères
il ya l'idée de revoir schengen et la
création du pôle isr ça vous fait réagir
toute l'histoire notamment va remettre à
plat schengen je faisais que sarkozy l'a
rappelé aux gens de la dir macro le 10
mai peu mais il faut que tout le monde
soit d'accord et surtout pour le revoir
dans le même sens le jour où les
espagnols les italiens les polonais sont
évertués qui sont d'accord pour revoir
le truc dans le même sens moi je pars le
matin puis si je pense que c'est une
plateforme qui doit réunir et sa part un
message on passe on passe par les
citoyens on vise aussi un certain nombre
de partis qui sont pas forcément au
pouvoir mais on fait une majorité de
projet au parlement reconnaissant d'avis
les les polonais les jours meilleurs les
italiens les espagnols les français ne
sont pas d'accord parce que peut-être
qu'il nous parlait même mais en tout cas
ils ne sont pas d'accord donc dire la
préférence européenne moi je suis à fond
pour wii s'est très bien tahrir au caire
le pareil j'ai besoin de sarko l'europe
byron actes et tout ça on n'est pas sûr
que les allemands veulent pas les pays
léonard dorin par les pays bas veulent
pas bon ben on va faire comment on va
pas les forcer à pratiquer c'est
d'éviter les sujets et puis on les bouge
il ya un jour mais la maturité kfw que
c'est ça arrive que le président
république française s'adressant tout le
monde mais lise le cours sur un truc que
ça va faire avancer ces sujets là qui
sont bloqués je le regrette depuis pour
les uns une plateforme incidemment
consensuel comme vous disiez tout à
l'heure pour qu'elle puisse justement
former une majorité de projet c'est en
tout cas ce qu'on peut souhaiter sur
franchement sur partager les
d'immigration entre les pays vous aurez
jamais être content mais vous avez noté
que courent sur le droit d'asile
oui ils évoqueront ce que vous allez
voir vous pensez que vous allez on va
arriver à un consensus de stress que
sarah liste des pays sûrs ça fait plus
de dix ans en dix ans qu'on cherche à
faire les pays sûr il suffirait de dire
je demain le sénégal la côte d'ivoire ce
défi surtout
on n'arrive même pas à se mettre
d'accord là dessus parce que je crois
aussi que l'échec du passé va nous
conduire à l'échec à l'avenir évidemment
on n'a plus qu'à pleurer
en tout cas ce que je crois c'est que
c'est plus compliqué que de mettre des
choses certes sympathiques sur une
feuille de papier on peut pas se
contenter de se réjouir des difficultés
de leurs oeuvres à jouer parce je mens
navre il ne faut pas se réjouir liste
non mais il faut espérer continuer à
travailler
monter petit à petit énormément de
décision dans l'histoire sont deux
réalités d'une longue longue longue
longue trace et tout d'un coup ça marche
assure faire tout type de politique pure
l'idée c'est quand même d'avoir un grand
parts de réunir autour de cette
plateforme le maximum d'eux
centristes de droite et de gauche c'est
l'explosion du parti populaire européen
aussi un vus de toute façon ce sera une
recomposition gère ce qui est
intéressant c'est parce qu'on démonte
c'est ce qu'on monte c'est à dire une
majorité de projet pour pouvoir avancer
sur ces différentes questions et
s'adresser aux citoyens européens c'est
aussi cela parce qu'en fait on est dans
un moment de tension monte doucement
dacia on va pas de faire les comptes à
la fin
comme celui nombril les pays européens
sont pas tous en train d'attendre ce que
dit on applique française et donc je
crois pas que tous me disent on va se
positionner par rapport à ce que dit
mâcon le l'italien l'allemand il ne ne
suppose que je pense que le but du break
se compensent en allemagne de ppe ne n'a
pas grand chose à voir ce que va dire
manuel mâcon c'est tout feu tout à fait
une autre d'autres débats gros on fait
un papier demain dans le journal je
crois pour les réactions justement à
l'étranger à cette tribune
on les a pas encore forcément tout
recenser paix a dit croire que c'est
beaucoup moins 9ème nombreux que ceux
heureuse que nous ne pouvons pas
assister impuissant en fait à la
progression des anti européens au
parlement européen sans rien faire donc
il faut une proposition alternative qui
soit le plus court la plus consensuelle
possible et les quelques mois qui
viennent de passer ont vu que c'est sur
un certain nombre de points on a réussi
à avancer comme mais ce que je
n'apparaissais beaucoup la parole à à
force de vouloir être consensuel
justement on maintient une équivoque
autour des européistes
je veux dire moi j'ai toujours voté pour
tous les traités et je m'aperçois
aujourd'hui qu'en fait c'est traiter ce
n'était pas pour construire une europe
puissance une europe puissance
économique politique de défense etc
mais c'était pour mieux s'intégrer dans
le marché mondial mais s'intégrer de à
la façon des libéraux c'est à dire en
justement
en ne mettant pas en place une
préférence européenne
non non plus autonome et non mais
justement s'intégrer de quelle façon
est-ce qu'on s'intègre en étant d'abord
intégrer l'europe intégrée c'est-à-dire
donc en protégeant nos frontières du
point de vue économique c'est le
grattoir comme le font les états unis
qui sont eux aussi intégrés dans le
marché mondial mais d'abord intégré
états unis donc moi je verrais bien une
intégration
c'est dans ce sens que je dis que je
suis fédéraliste ou et une intégration
mais d'abord de la fédération européenne
et puis pour mieux s'intégrer dans le
marché mondial bien entendu parce que
c'est ça que je reproche aux
nationalistes enfin au repli national
c'est que effectivement si on en revient
aux états-nations refermés sur eux-mêmes
vous savez très bien que justement vous
allez pas vous intégrer de façon
satisfaisante dans le marché mondial
c'est pour monter en puissance qu'on a
commencé à créer l'idée européenne
donc c'est pourquoi c'est une c'est une
une fausse opposition que soit on
retourne aux frontières nationales c'est
absurde et même ceux qui le disent ils
savent très bien que si absurde en fait
mais pourquoi elle ne distillent parce
qu'ils ne voient pas les frontières de
l'europe
si on construisait des frontières sûres
donc effectivement si c'est ça que veut
dire le président macron très bien mais
comme ils restent floues et justement
qu'ils cherchent encore à concilier la
chèvre et le chou c'est à dire les pays
bas et nous par exemple on va pas en
sortir et c'est encore allée très vite
gagner gagner les élections européennes
un braque matisse me révolue mais c'est
pas que ça c'est assez ferme et le
programme va suivre avec beaucoup plus
de détails évidemment on vous poser la
question sur lefigaro.fr avez vous été
convaincu par la tribune des mannes
macron pour relancer l'europe vous
n'êtes pas tout à fait convaincu puisque
vous êtes exactement enfin deux tiers
67% à ne pas l'être
on va parler d'un sujet très voisin
puisqu'il s'agit de jean pierre raffarin
l'européen c'est donc par une interview
au figaro que l'ancien premier ministre
a choisi d'annoncer son soutien au
projet européen emmanuel macron et il
fera donc campagne pour en marche un pas
de côté de plus pour l'ancien premier
ministre qui a déjà sérieusement pris
ses distances avec les républicains de
laurent wauquiez alors comment
jugez-vous cette démarche n'est-elle
qu'une clarification individuelles ou
une étape dans la recomposition de la
droite on en parle dans un instant mais
avant deux réactions chez les
républicains tout d'abord celle de la
tête de liste européenne françois xavier
bellamy qui minimisent écoutez le et je
crois que la clarification était
nécessaire jean pierre raffarin
partaient partager déjà des réunions
stratégiques avec le président de la
république il ya quelques semaines de
cela sur le projet européen